well welcome to the third in the series
of of algebra of age word problems and i
just wanted to uh start off where i left
off in the second one i got myself
confused you guys make me very nervous
while you just sit there and listening
and i have to perform for you but it
turns out we did get the right answer if
you say armand is 153 and thirush is
765. then 85 years ago armand would have
been 68
and thurush would have been 680 and that
notice that's 10 times
so it worked out so we're ready to
tackle another problem and we'll do one
more problem let's see
okay now i need to
type to type and i want to type big
so you can see it
this problem says
zach
is four
times
as
old as salman what a coincidence salman
really shows up in a lot of problems
zach is four times as old as salman
zak
is also
three
years older
than
salman
how
old
is
zach
well actually this one actually seems uh
fairly straightforward we're not dealing
with the present and the future we're
just dealing with the present so let's
see if we can figure this out
so we're trying to figure out how old is
zach let's say z for zach z equals zach
i don't like this big fat well i'll
stick with the big fat marker z is zach
it says zach is four times as old as
something i'm gonna go to then i don't
like how big fat this is
so salman if zach is z this first
sentence
let me circle it
zack is four times as old
as salman
so if zach is four times as old as
salman then that means that
sal
is equal to
zack
divided by four
or
uh well i can see that we could just
leave it like that
but then it also says here let me put
this in a different color
that zach is also
three years older than salman
well if zach is also three years older
than salman so that means that also
sal would be
zach
minus 3 right the first sentence says
zach is four times as old as salman well
that means that if you take zach's age
and divide it by four you get sal's age
the second sentence says zack is also
three years older than salman so that
takes it means if you take zach's age
and you subtract 3 from it you get sal's
age again
well we have our equation set up and
actually instead of writing zach i
should have just written z but the
equation is all set up for us and we get
z
over 4 is equal to z minus 3. you can
multiply both sides of this equation
times 4 and we'll get
z
is equal to 4z remember to distribute it
minus 12.
and then we just do skip a couple of
steps and i get 3 z
is equal to 12 and i get zach
is equal to 4
years
old
let's see if that makes sense if zack is
4 years old then this first sentence
says zach is four times as old as salman
so that means
sal
is one years old
and it also says zach is three years
older than salman well that's consistent
four is three more than one so we were
right zach is exactly 4 years old hope
that helps have fun i think you're ready
you've now seen at least every type of
uh the age word problems if you're still
confused you might just want to re-watch
the videos and maybe pause it right
after i give you the problem and see if
you can solve it yourself and and
remember you got a lot of practice
problems you can do on the actual
modules themselves have fun